I just want to thank you all sincerely
for coming out and being a part of this
event I've been doing comedy almost 10
years and this is a moment where I'm
really going all-in on myself and trying
to create an opportunity inspires others
to do the same so this is how comedy
specials go most comics do like for
recordings of their comedy specials
Joel's doing it in one and it looks like
a half right now
I got to admit I am a trophy husband I
will admit it
it's a participation trophy I married
the perfect wife she has a tattoo so she
can handle permanent mistakes
you brought the dog of course relieving
aside
[Music]
it's alright come people ask me like
what I'm having kids like I don't want
kids not until I have unlimited data
it's also kind of scary to have a kid
right now because I don't know the world
is ending or not
I hear the sea levels are rising then I
hear half of America's obese so I don't
know if the seas are rising we're here
just sinking so I want to in my special
on a joke my wife told me not to do hey
Joe lovers I am so excited to release
this comedy special after 10 years in
the game I got frustrated with waiting
on someone else's approval and decided
to produce my own comedy special to
inspire other comics to do the same if
you want to join me on this journey
click the link right here
pick up the comedy special and let's do
this
[Music]